et vincent une petite surprise pour vous
ils sont là les daft punk sont là je
vais vous dire déjà merci les daft punk
merci d'être là
ah oui c'est qu'en tant qu au mental et
on est très heureux d'être là vous
regarde tous les pouvoirs et d'ailleurs
on adore quand tu paies la danse de
l'épaule les harcèlements ball aaa à aa
au gérant courir alors la question que
j'ai envie de vous poser est où vous
regardez l'émission tous les soirs quel
est votre chroniqueur préféré les daft
punk c'est important pour les
téléspectateurs des gens dit elle mais
surtout quand il dit qu'il avait matin
qu'il avait deux dernières questions et
merci vraiment d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir ce sera la dernière question dit
opposé à preview vous laissez bien sûr
repartir vous avez remporté cinq grammy
awards comment c'était la remise des
prix whaou était génial génial génial
tout ce qui se passe attendez mais c'est
pas leaders pour ses vaches idole
je suis anna qui écoutent mois
missionnaire de trout bas et la
moustache elle fait décoller en dessous
je n'ai comme ça oh là là j'ai cru qu'on
allait pas y arriver alors vous êtes à
moustache mais j'ai passé on va jouer
avec les téléspectateurs on va jouer à
chercher des animateurs c'est ça ouais
bien sûr votre personnalité la
télévision de à trouver aujourd'hui
attention à vous joindre et chez vous
tout seul autre c'est pourquoi il est en
promo à 42 et on a foulé aux aurores
problèmes comme ça roule
un bébé de 20 mois
travailler sur m6 ou deux fois
avec ses sourcils très fourni avec moi
que ceux de léopard
avant de films érotiques et si c'est lui
qui voit là
un superbe o'shea une veste orange
bagarres et des yeux qui sortent de
pézenas et je sais pas si tu te souviens
trouillas qu'avant la pub ça faisait
comme ça
m
est-ce que vous avez tué
l'innovation réside et danseurs j'ai
entendu le début avec le sourcil donc
forcément j'ai pour salies mane et le
chant voilà ce laboratoire cherche une
émission de télé la tension assez
cherché également chez vous écoutez bien
les paroles et s'est proposé
j'ai des maisons cuisine qui passe sur
m6 tous les lundis oui mais à quel ça
commence à 20h55 et ça se termine
à peu près au cours du salon qui dit
pourquoi tu es ça il faut
moi ça me
il a été choisi pour tous le texte est
passé communiste a répondu non à londres
et à répondre en français merci les gars
gera si gallas et moment donné si
plaisir de vous retrouver
sa mission